bonsoir thomas alors prenons en compte
les interventions sur l'ensemble du
globe le rapport présente pourtant des
chiffres certainement en dessous de la
réalité absolument à en croire le
document publié ce mercredi par le
ministère de la défense américaine 23
civils ont été tués sur l'ensemble de
l'année 2020 lors d'opérations
militaires américaines dans le détail
vingt civils sont morts en afghanistan
un a été tué en somalie au mois de
février 1 en irak au mois de mars et on
ignore l'origine du 23e civils tués pour
parvenir à ces chiffres les autorités
américaines ont étudié des centaines de
rapports de terrain et même les réseaux
sociaux afin de livrer ce document
destiné à une commission spéciale du
congrès une partie seulement est rendue
publique
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que ces chiffres sont contestés
plusieurs ong estiment que le bilan est
très nettement inférieur à la réalité il
ya par exemple la ngr wars qui est
spécialisé dans les questions de 6000
depuis en opération militaire et bien
cette ong indiquent que le bilan le plus
prudent ferait état d'au moins 102
civils tués soit presque cinq fois plus
que le bilan officiel qui nous a été
présenté par le pentagone pour vous
donner une idée la mission de l'onu en
afghanistan dénombre pour sa part 89
morts civils
rien que dans ce pays où le gros de la
coalition militaire occidentale est
composée de soldats américains
autre élément intéressant dans ce
rapport du pentagone on peut y lire qu'à
un budget annuel de 3 millions de
dollars est prévu pour dédommager les
familles des victimes et bien sûr
l'année 2020 les autorités américaines
ont versé 0 aucune aide donc été
attribué
merci beaucoup à vous de m'abonner en
direct depuis washington